speaking of wellness a lot of you may be
sniffling and sneezing as it is allergy
season rocky spoke with the doctor from
optum care lung analogy the sponsors of
this segment about what you need to know
to manage the allergies here in southern
nevada
we know when we see you we're talking
seasonal allergies spring is around the
corner so let's get ready what do we
need to know what should we expect for
southern nevada allergies
well
allergy season is here with the coming
of the warmer weather
allergy season is definitely here we can
expect increased allergy symptoms
because of increased exposure exposure
to pollen
the major sources of allergies for
springtime here in southern nevada is
mainly from poland from certain trees
specifically
olive trees as well as mulberry trees we
also have pollen from other trees but
these are the two major pollinating
trees that's
causes nasal nasal and allergy symptoms
in nevada we also have pollen from
various grasses particularly bermuda
grass which is one of the most notorious
sources of
allergens here in southern nevada along
with johnson and kentucky grass are
there more symptoms other than the runny
nose and the itchy and the itchy eyes
that we need to be aware of
sure there's the five major symptoms of
the nose congestion
stuffy itches sneezy runny and drainy
the postnasal drip with the eyes usually
itchy watery eyes and occasional eyelid
swelling now for people who have
very severe allergies it can cause sinus
pressure headaches and unfortunately it
can also trigger
asthma symptoms now is that is that a
bigger problem especially now with you
know covet and all of these other
illnesses that we're worried about
yes it is
because one of the major triggers of
asthma along with allergies is
respiratory tract infections
and if you have uncontrolled allergies
unfortunately you are more susceptible
to these infections
so
if you have allergies you are more than
likely you're more attractive to viruses
and germs because there's actually
certain things happening in the lining
of your nose that make you more
attractive to these infectious agents
that is a great point that's good to
know um what are the best ways to
control these symptoms
well we can group it according into two
one is environmental control meaning
control what you can control so if you
have pets at home that you're allergic
to then you can kind of love your pets
from a distance and
learn to
have established boundaries if your
allergies are mainly to pollen from
outdoors it's best to keep your windows
closed use air conditioning pollen is
highest in the early morning hours of
course don't forget to take your
medicine right
you got it right and so for some people
who are known to have allergies
seasonally you can use your medications
regularly during the seasons that you
have allergies and this can be in the
form of oral medication spills
or nose sprays and for the most
definitive treatment of allergies
allergy shots for those people who are
in allergy shots best be diligent in
getting your shots
our thanks to optum care lung analogy
for sponsoring this segment there are
several locations across southern nevada
for more information you can call that
number on your screen 702-724-8844